[Music]
the Thursday edition of PFT ot we are
only four days away from the return of
PFT live and I'm a couple of days away
from getting this toupee adjusted for
any of you who think it's a toupee
have you noticed it's grown I haven't
gotten to cut the entire time that we've
been off I thought about not shaving
either I made it about thirty hours
before I realized I can't pull it off I
can't not itch like crazy and it just
looks really really bad there's a lot
more gray on my face then there is in my
hair I guess that's a good thing
alright here's not a good thing for the
New Orleans Saints Michael Thomas star
receiver trying to get a new contract
and doing the ultimate thing that a
player can do to exert leverage on the
team with holding services holding out
at the start of New Orleans Saints
training camp there's been indications
that progress has been made between the
two sides but they still had a bit of a
gap a couple of million per year and of
course structure and guarantees will be
part of it but Michael Thomas has has
woefully over performed is that even
does that make sense
he has tremendously over performed his
rookie contract and it's time for him to
get paid the question is coming up with
a number that makes sense and he'd like
to be reportedly the first 20 million
dollar per year guy we'll see if he can
pull that off he's drawing that line in
the sand and holding out in order to
make it happen couple of things to keep
in mind first the standard find for a
training camp holdout is 40,000 dollars
per day now a lot of times that money
never gets paid but still for the guy
who's holding out you are consciously
walking into a potential obligation of
$40,000 per day secondly the August
sixth deadline we've talked about it as
it relates to Zico Elliott I've talked
about it as it relates to Chris Jones
the Chiefs defensive lineman has relates
to Michael Thomas he needs to be back by
August 6 or he won't get a year of
credit toward free agency meaning that
assuming he shows up by the Tuesday
after week 10 he gets credit for the
contract year but he's still a
three-year player when it's time for him
to become a free agent
next year when his contract expires that
means restricted free agency instead of
unrestricted free agency that means the
highest possible RFA tender instead of a
franchise tag for Michael Thomas
and then the question becomes is he
comfortable telling the saints go ahead
apply the highest are FA tender somebody
will gladly give up a first-round pick
in order to make an offer to me that you
may not match so some additional steps
that will become clear in the coming
days assuming the Saints don't give
Thomas a deal
maybe they blink maybe they get this
done maybe the holdout Spurs action and
Thomas is back in the fold quickly we'll
see how that one plays out we know how
it's playing out for the LA Chargers
Melvin Gordon has begun his holdout now
because he's in the fifth year of a
five-year first round rookie contract a
couple of things don't apply to him
first of all the August 6 deadline
doesn't matter he has his four years of
credit he will be an unrestricted free
agent after this contract expires he
just needs to show up by the Tuesday
after week 10 also the fines are lower
for him than they are for other players
by rule for a player operating under
that fifth year option it's only thirty
thousand dollars per day not forty
thousand dollars per day however there's
another side to it we learned this last
year's are related to Khalil Mack if you
miss a preseason game as a player
operating under a fifth-year option
contract you're fined for missing that
game is the equivalent of your
regular-season game check so from Melvin
Gordon five point six oh five million
that he's due to make this year divided
by 17 that's what he'll be giving up for
every preseason game he misses basically
he's giving up regular season game
checks by missing preseason games now
again with the team pursue that who
knows but it's part of the risk that you
assume as a player who takes advantage
of the power to hold out and there's
going to be people out there who say oh
he's signed a contract
he needs to honor his contract look two
contracts apply to NFL players one the
contract between them and the team to
the contract between the league and the
NFL Players Association the player has
rights the player has powers now the
player also has obligations under the
broader contract and if the player is
willing to assume the risk that the team
will indeed collect those fines the play
can withhold services without breaching
the broader contract and regardless of
anything that may be in his individual
contract with his club bottom line is
the bigger picture for the NFL gives
players the right to hold out it doesn't
matter that they have a contract they
can hold out if they're willing to incur
the downside for staying away all right
Jana can gawk way Jaguars defensive end
also has held out he falls into the
chris jones michael thomas category guys
entering the fourth year of their
contracts guys who have over performed
slotted rookie wait scale deals guys who
are trying to get that big money before
they forced their way to the open market
or to the franchise tag the reason for
all of his is you want to shift the
injury risk to the team because anything
can happen in this fourth year you know
Todd Gurley was in a different kind of a
situation last year but we learned that
by Gurley getting his new contract from
the Rams right he got it then there's no
way the Rams would give it to him now
because of what happened last year with
his knee it is important for guys who
have established themselves as great
players to come up with a way to try to
get their contracts before that final
year of injury risk that falls on the
player comes their way because it could
change everything and by next year that
player may not be nearly as attractive
as he is now Falcons receiver Julio
Jones still waiting for his new contract
is we've discussed earlier this week
plenty of people believe that the
Falcons already have a contract in place
for Julio Jones it's just a matter of
time before they announce it and they
have to wait until after Friday the 26th
of July because that's the one year
anniversary of last year's new contract
for Julio Jones so it's coming we think
and what else is coming Julio Jones
hopes is a 3,000 yard receiving season
yes yes I didn't misspeak I often do but
on that point 3,000 yards that's what
Julio Jones once now keep in mind
no one's ever had a 2,000 yard receiving
season Amari Cooper the Cowboys told me
earlier this summer that he's shooting
for 2,000 about fell out of the chair
Julio Jones is taking it a level higher
and I understand what guys are doing
when they set these ridiculously high
goals
they I think they they're willing to do
it because they think it's gonna will
them to have a bigger year than they
would otherwise have if they didn't have
an outlandish goal but this is the time
of year where teams and players are just
flat-out delusional and Julio Jones can
think all he wants he's got a shot at
3,000 games that is a ridiculous pace
that no one has ever been on and I think
there was a time last year when Michael
Thomas based on the first couple of
games was on a ridiculous pace for
catches in yards but it never lasts
because eventually what's gonna happen
if you're having the kind of year it's
gonna give you 3,000 yards the opposing
defense is gonna put five guys on you if
they have to to slow you down so it's
fun to talk about but it's it's it's
laughable to think that anyone would say
310 when no one's ever had 2,000 that's
a thousand yards more than what no one
has ever done before in the 99 year
history of the league 3,000 yards it's
like somebody there's there's been a two
thousand yard rusher how ludicrous would
it be if somebody said I'm gonna rush
for 2,000 yards this year well that's
less ludicrous than what Julio Jones has
said Julian Edelman the defending Super
Bowl MVP is gonna miss some time in
training camp it turns out he has a
broken thumb a broken thumb reportedly
suffered while he's playing catch a few
weeks ago which reminds you that you
know anything can happen at any time and
now Edelman's gonna take some time to
get ready to go no indication who miss
any of the regular season remember last
year he missed the first four games due
to a PE d suspension this year he should
be ready to roll when the Patriots host
the Steelers week one and this is gonna
be a crazy year for the Patriots as
relates to the receiving corps because
Gronk is gone it's Julian Edelman and in
kill Harry the first-round draft pick as
the top two guys and who knows how it
falls out after that so they need
Edelman there that is Tom Brady's safety
blanket and what they need to be doing
is developing another safety blanket for
Tom Brady because Julian Edelman who
knows how much longer he has who knows
how much longer Brady has but it just
seems like with the Patriots it all
keeps moving in the right direction
it's not moving in the right direction
for the Packers and veteran defensive
lineman Mike Daniels abruptly
on Wednesday the Packers cut the court
on their relationship with Daniels that
surprised a lot of people as it turns
out and this was explained yesterday by
Packers GM Brian
because they tried to trade him and they
couldn't the remote Apple teams
reportedly interested now why wouldn't
they be able to trade him well he was
due to make over seven and a half
million dollars in salary this year the
Packers thought he's not worthy of it
based on where he is in this career at
this point and no other team was willing
to throw a seventh round pick a sixth
round pick a fifth round pick Green
Bay's way to buy his contract you know a
lot of times when a trade happens of a
veteran player the trade gets done
because you'd like that contract because
you know if the guy gets cut it's gonna
cost you a lot more on the open market
to get him so now the question becomes
what will someone pay Mike Daniels on
the open market and can his agent create
enough competition among multiple teams
to drive that number up and I wouldn't
be surprised if at the end of the day
there's kind of a face-saving contract
where he can earn up to the money he was
due to making Green Bay through
incentives escalators etc but if anyone
was gonna pay him when he was due to
make with the Packers this year they
likely would have given the Packers
something and the Packers would have
taken anything they get no compensation
for cutting Mike Daniels this isn't like
a normal free agent deal where the guys
contract expires he signs with a new
team and you get a compensatory drafting
you get nothing when you cut a guy so
the Packers would have taken anything
and no one was willing to offer anything
to get his contract that tells me
wherever he lands he's going to be
making less than he was due to make with
the Green Bay Packers and that's it for
Thursday's pft ot we'll have one more
tomorrow and then Monday we are back
Sims we'll be back I'll still be here
but we'll be on NBC sports radio and
NBCSN starting Monday July the 29th and
continuing indefinitely or until they
pull us off the air we will be on line
around-the-clock a pro football talk
calm we'll see you there we'll see you
here we'll see you everywhere but at a
minimum we'll see you back here again
[Music]
you